can you explain the three elements of
creating a horror movie
yeah it's a great question that comes
from blake snyder's idea
about the monster in the house because
blake has this really wonderful
elegant way of thinking about genre
that's different than what most people
think about genre when most people think
about genre they think of sci-fi or
western or horror or this or that or the
other
and blake was like well that doesn't
really help you write a screenplay
what's a way of thinking about genre a
way of sort of unified elements that's
gonna
keep you focused on what's map what
matters for you to
um create a screenplay with core
elements that has like the tuning fork
that sounds like
wonderful expression of that genre
so um one of my favorites
is that monster in the house genre and
and that requires a monster of some sort
right
um but it need not be like supernatural
could even be like a psychopath
or or you know um something terrible um
and then a house that's um that's
confined the protagonist
so that it's um so they can't get away
right so that the monster is chasing
them because if uh there's no house then
there's no tension
right the stakes are there because they
can't get away from the monster because
they're stuck in the house together
and then the most fascinating part about
it is the sin that's the third part
and the why is sin and it's because
monster monster in the house movies are
a morality tale of when we
when you do something bad bad things
happen
so uh you know the classic um you know
kids type teenagers go into the woods to
have
pre-marital sex well then the bad
thing's gonna happen the slasher is
gonna come out and kill them right
um but without that sin they're just
kind of you know
a couple walking their dog by the woods
and they get killed
it doesn't quite doesn't quite hit us in
that same way
because we're all attracted to sin and
we all sin to some degree or another
and so monster-in-the-house stories
play on that vice
choice and terrible response and that's
part of the titillation of great horror
and what's also really wonderful about
what blake thought about in that theory
is that
he then said if you look at a movie like
jaws
um where the monster is the shark and
the contained
the house is the cont is the island
where you know the sort of the
amity island which was sort of like the
hamptons but like you know this
contained place
um and then the sin was that um
they knew the threat was there but they
didn't shut down
the town or didn't keep people away from
the beach because
it was a tourist town and they needed
the money or they wanted the money the
greed
was the same so that makes the that's
such an
interesting story and compelling in a
different way than if it didn't have
that element
but then blake really ingeniously said
a movie like fatal attraction he would
also put in that monster in the house
things
what you know certainly jaws is like a
horror movie but how would you
fail attractions like this kind of
psychological thriller but let's
look at the three elements you've got
the monster which is glenn close playing
the psychopathic woman who just
was obsessed with this guy
you've got the house was literally the
end was the house but it was really kind
of the family unit
right and the sin was adultery
so you have that same primal
pattern of you know wanting something
that you really shouldn't go after and
you do it anyway and it brings out the
monster and then all hell breaks loose
great example so that doesn't
necessarily have to be a horror film
it can be a thriller it could be a drama
um
i mean did you see dark waters i didn't
see doctors oh okay
all right we'll go into that one yeah
but it it can it absolutely can
transcend what traditionally we think of
as genres it could be sci-fi
western it could be anything um the key
is
to blake's mind which i thought was
really great was
that core pattern you're gonna chances
of
making a writing a script that makes a
deeper impact on people
is is much more likely if you take those
three elements and you sort of build
your story around those elements
no matter what sort of external genre
you place on it
does every genre have a certain amount
of elements a writer must know
yeah yeah they do it's um
because what we're doing is
we're taking the audience on a very
personal journey even if it's a comedy
or whatever it is and
the genre is the set of expectations
that the audience is has been promised
for them to plunk down their money to
see the story
so if i promise them a comedy and it's
not
funny they're gonna be pissed off and
rightly so
um if it's a horror movie uh it's gotta
be scary
it's a thriller it has to have tension
um
and uh so a lot of
beginning writers don't realize that
they're not seeing it as a relationship
with the audience with these promises
and genres are all about promises and
expectations
and sometimes beginning writers will
go oh i've got this cool idea and it's
kind of this genre and it's kind of
where that genre and it's kind of like
that
and it's like yeah that's really
creative and
you are planning to alienate your
audience
um and it almost never works um there's
some genres that can kind of um
play nice together um uh you know
one that a lot of people try to do but
verily very rarely get
get right is like horror comedy um edgar
wright i think does it masterfully
better than anybody that i've seen but
it's really hard and it's really hard
because
comedy is so particular and so the
comedy has to be great
and then the amount of fear and the
scares has to be great so you're talking
about
two really high bars that are particular
that's why most don't work well and i
think that
getting back to the other point is that
just early screenwriters
sometimes when i when i work with
screenwriters they um
it's one of the ways that their
creativity gets
in the way that they um they it's like
they um
they're building a car and they put
triangle wheels on the car
and um that car is not going to go it is
going to be super creative it's going to
be really cool and i
honor them for coming up with those
ideas but um
it's not going to get them to where they
want to go so um
there's ways where you just you know
don't you
take the round wheel you can make a big
round wheel or small round wheel but
make it a round wheel
um and then the creativity on top of
that then you can go wild
so there's yeah that's a common problem
that earlier writers have
they don't know which boxes can be
totally crazy
and need to be crazy and and different
and which boxes are really more like an
engineering problem they just don't mess
with that
and genre is absolutely one of those
ones where
you generally don't mess with it you go
you give them what they want
and give them a spin on it but it's
really what they want um
you know even tarantino who has a deep
understanding of
movies and genre you know one of his i
think least successful movies was um
from dusk till dawn that he made with
rodriguez and i think it was just
because it was
it was a horror crime film and it
started literally started out as i think
more of a crime film and then took this
crazy left turn
into a vampire movie um which
even just saying it sounds like one of
those hey wouldn't it be cool
and then it was like this and then these
vampires came out you know
and um you know those guys were at a
point in their career where they were
killing it and um
they're like yeah this is really cool
and they loved it and you know and
people
you know uh i don't know if it was
profitable probably it might have been
profitable or not i don't think it was
um or maybe over time it became
profitable but like ultimately i think
it's a really good case study of
an interesting idea but
a fairly low ceiling in terms of how
many people are really going to love it
and i'm sure some people are like i love
that movie it's my favorite okay
great and if your objective is to
deliver your voice and service to your
audience as powerfully as possible for
as broad of an
audience as possible stick to one genre
and nail that genre and go take that
genre to the new place
give it a fresh spin on where it's going
next
the audience gaining trust the
screenwriter
gaining trust of their audience is is it
different
than this genre promise
no it's the same the one way
to establish trust with the audience is
if i you know
i've shown them a log line and it's this
particular genre and on page one they're
seeing
that it already feels like this genre on
page one
now i'm establishing more trust and if
i'm paid if i'm if it's a comedy and
there's nothing funny on page one
problems and what about this
i hate to call it self-delusion but i'll
just use that for lack of a better term
of a writer thinking they're taking
genre to new heights
but they're not really doing that
they're mixing it they're they're
playing with it in ways that really
aren't taking into new heights so i love
that question
because um it to me it feels like
their intention is dead on and the
execution is a mess so um
if they have a high quality feedback
loop system
um it will tell them you know it'll be
like look i wanna
i think i'm gonna have some action and
i'm gonna have some comedy and i'm gonna
do this i'm gonna have that and um
the response to that sort of thing is
like
look this is it's kind of like a little
bit of a lot of things and i'd rather
have a lot of one thing
um if they're getting high quality
feedback um and
then that person can go huh because i
thought it was kind of cool okay well
i'm going to make it anyway if i'm
independent filmmaker
and then it'll play regional festivals
or whatever
or not at all but like if you want to
blow people away
then you do sort of less from a deeper
place
and you fulfill that promise of genre of
these other things in a way that's
profound
and feels fresh and new so it's the same
but different it's familiar
but fresh um and uh
yeah genre is one of the best ways to do
it and so the person that's kind of like
in that scatter place or they've got all
these mishmashes um
again it's fine you know but they just
have to just compare the apples to
apples i'm trying to
you know here's a comparable again
they're if they compare one apple that
they're trying to do with four different
apples that's the problem
right no give timmy one
movie that had this particular genre
that you loved that was successful that
you you'd love to have that sort of
success with your screenplay
what's that apple how you create your
apple and then you figure out
how you sort of can make them the same
so quentin tarantino tells this great
story
about when he was acting in the 80s
and uh he had this acting and at that
point in the 80s you know you couldn't
get
there was no internet so you couldn't
get scripts online you had to kind of
like watch the movies and
you know take notes and so he's in his
acting class and he um
you know wrote down the scene from this
movie and handed it to his acting
partner and goes like you know we're
going to act in this
in the scene together and um and
the scene the scene partner goes well
holy this monologue isn't in the
movie
and quentin's like what oh geez i'm
sorry he goes no no this is better than
what's in the movie right
and so um the takeaway there for the for
the amateur writer
is um what he did inadvertently was
realized that
he as a writer was nailing at a really
high level
so um amateur writers can use or any
writer can i use it all the time to sort
of
compare apples to apples with any sort
of element if i'm trying to get better
at let's say tension
or you know certain dialogue or
genre whatever i look at what i think is
the standard for what i'm trying to do
in another
thing and then i do my version of it and
i try to
get the apple to the apple to be the
same in my view and then i get feedback
and are they looking at it and going
yeah brooks i can't tell which one was
written by you and which one was written
by
you know legend a or whatever now now
i'm good
it's like fan fiction almost i was doing
an early version of it
yeah yeah that's right that's right it
was a good look at it that's exactly it
and if you can do fan fiction that's as
good
um you know i mean yeah i mean there's
you can you can get work that way if you
can play in that universe
in a way that's as powerful as the you
know the people that are already there
sure so if i'm writing let's say a
thriller and i think oh wow i'm gonna
really this is this
the thriller genre but i'm gonna take it
to new heights and let's suppose it's
like a wall street corruption
story and somebody is the cleaning lady
and she ends up
seeing people shredding documents but
then the people that are really the bad
guys turn out to be like reptilian
society people and
that's i'm almost that's not really
taking it to a new height
that's mixing genres because now i've
got some sci-fi in there and
they don't need to be reptiles you see
what i'm saying so i'm mixing but i
my assumption is i think oh i'm going to
take this to new heights
but if i don't get that feedback from
the feedback loop
then i'm going to be delusional and
thinking that this is just like never
been seen before
so so what i'll say about that is yeah i
think that the word delusional is sort
of a charged
word that feels a little distracting
because
in this hypothetical where somebody's
like i'm trying to take the genre to a
new place
perfect that's exactly what we're doing
that's exactly what everything is
that we love has done it takes something
not everything but a lot of
things that really break ground it's
because they're doing that so that
intention is dead on
and the truth is it takes trial and
error to be able to get that it's like i
want to make the best
new heist film ever right awesome um
that's what i'm trying to do where am i
at now so to say where i'm at how is
delusional i was like okay
fine but like i mean it's kind of a
negative way of saying it's just like
you you are where you are
and then and then you just kind of
figure out here's what i'm trying to get
to here's where i am now
how do i sort of get there and um
and being gentle with ourselves and
thinking of ourselves or other people is
like delusional is kind of a
this is a distracting way of of the
matter-of-fact business of
getting the apple to match the apple and
if um
and the impulse to go the way that i'm
going to take it to that next level is
adding a bit of this genre that genre
um maybe it's just you know it's it's
sort of
like um you know you see you're gonna
get a feel for these things you know i
mean it's like sometimes some genres
do have aspects that do play nice
together you know or harmonize really
nice together
um and some things kind of clash you
know they're sort of um
you know somebody can you know do a
website design or just a set of colors
and some people have a knack for like
those colors look nice again or like the
way you dress you know
some people can do it some people can't
people like it and we don't but like
it's that set of artistic choices that
harmonize together or not and so um
so uh it's a matter of playing with
which story elements end up harmonizing
in the right way
to get to that point where you're taking
the genre the next level so
i would never describe it as delusional
when they're in the process of doing the
damn thing that they should be doing
you